interesting business angle for the nfl
that needs to be addressed it's
popped up from time to time in recent
weeks and it's going to get
resolved sooner than later for a couple
of reasons first of all most of the tv
deals for the nfl
run through 2022 one of them one of the
biggest ones
monday 21. peter king had some reporting
in football morning in america
about the reality that the nfl is
closing in on a new round of deals that
would go for 10
years jabari young of cnbc had some
information last week as well suggesting
that
the nfl wants to finalize the framework
of these deals before
setting the next salary cap which tells
me miles this 100 billion dollars in
total value over the next 10 years
quite possibly will get shuffled around
a little bit
to help boost the cap in a year that it
otherwise would be depressed
due to the pandemic from 198.2 down to
180
maybe some of this new money this new tv
money will
slide into 2021 and up goes the cap and
it makes it easier for some of these
teams
that are in real cap trouble to operate
this year
yeah and not only will it help those
teams i mean it helps these players man
because
i think we're gonna see a lot of veteran
guys
don't have that much guaranteed money
left on their contract start to get cut
and when you talk about that that is
kind of this middle class right there of
football
veterans who are you know probably into
their second contract
maybe moving into their 30s people who
can still be productive
but they're going to get a little more
expensive because they're going to
command more salary because
they have more experience so i think the
sooner they can get this
done the better and if that does affect
the cap and they're
able to push that thing up a little bit
further it's only going to benefit
everybody mike and i think that's
probably why they want to get it done so
quickly
prime example jj watt falls right into
that category
guy on the wrong side of 30 not a
superstar anymore
how can any team know what it can offer
him without knowing what the cap
is going to be that extra million or two
you give to jj watt is the thing that
may cause you to cut
some other players one or more of them
that would otherwise be an important
part of the broader cause
in 2021 or the extra money you give to
watt that's less money you'd have
to maybe go grab a free agent who gets
cut
by another team a guy who's available or
a guy who didn't get the offer that he
wanted and he's willing to do a one-year
deal
to join your team so everyone needs to
know
what the cap is going to be clark hunt
the chairman of the league's finance
committee said before the super bowl
that they may not know what the cap is
until just hours before the start of the
new league year on march 17.
so these tv deals could go a long way
toward
pumping them up or at least keeping the
salary cap from
falling quite as far as many think the
prevailing
thought continues to be neighborhood 180
million
one of the factors it's still unknown
what's the expected attendance for 2021
that could help drive up the number a
little bit as well it's all part of a
negotiation between the league and the
union but before the league in the union
can negotiate on what the cap will be
the league's got to have an agreement
the team's got to have an agreement and
miles for strategic reasons
some of these teams are sitting on a
mountain cap space their position may be
hey sucks to be you let's go you got to
cut some guys
sorry you should have kept more cap
space back in the event of some
unexpected
development like this one yeah if you're
the browns and you've got a bunch of cap
space and you're seeing jj watt out
there and you're like hey man
it doesn't necessarily matter what the
cap is gonna be we know we want you
and we can probably pay you a little bit
more than some of these other teams that
are very close
to either being super bowl contenders or
are already super bowl contenders if you
want to ring chase
look we're cleveland and yeah we know
that we haven't been very good for very
long
and we've been really bad for a really
long time but you can really be part of
the piece that helps take us over the
top
and if you're that and you can say that
to jj watt and you can present him with
a good contract with a good salary
before you know what the cap is then
you're in a better situation than a lot
of
other teams are right now and mike i
think that could really
be one of the determining factors in
where jj walk goes
so here's where the tv deals are likely
to stand and let me just
preface these comments by saying i have
no inside information nbc only wakes me
up for the unimportant meetings
the reporting that others have pushed
forward
suggests that cbs and fox will keep the
sunday afternoon package as they have
for years now nbc likely to keep
expected to keep
will keep sunday night football a
package that nbc has had
since 2006. thursday night football is
one of the wild cards
none of the three-letter networks want
it apparently
amazon may get it the problem is it's
not going to have that three-letter
broadcast platform where you get
20 million or more people tuning in
people are going to have to stream it
maybe it'll be on nfl network but that
becomes something
that has less value as it relates to the
infomercial aspect all the people who
tune in to watch this game
you're not going to have that on
thursday night and miles i think that
makes it more important
if thursday night is a non-three-letter
network
night monday night needs to be a
three-letter network night it needs to
be
espn abc simulcast
that's the last domino that apparently
needs to fall
with the other wrinkle being sunday
ticket there's been talk of espn plus
inheriting the streaming aspect from
directv
i think it would be wise to keep with
directv the satellite
element because there are still plenty
of people who don't have the kind of
internet
service needed to stream games but still
have out in the middle of nowhere that
satellite dish that allows them to pull
all the games
off of the satellite so that feels like
where it's heading
but until it gets there we don't know
for sure but multiple reports are kind
of lining it up that way
i think the thursday night part of this
is super interesting because
basically when thursday night football
started it used to be this thing where
it's like oh boy
what afc south uh match up are we
watching here you know the tennessee
titans
and the jacksonville jaguars are playing
on thursday night and it seems like this
is always what happens and
who is marcus mariota gonna throw a
touchdown pass to
it's different now because it's been on
nbc
on cbs on fox so you needed
better matchups and fox has really
gotten that in the last few years but
if this thing goes to amazon i think
it's going to start rolling that back
where
the premium matchups really won't
necessarily be on thursday night anymore
because you're just frankly not going to
have the same amount of eyeballs on that
thing as you did
when it was on a three-letter network so
that's one really
fascinating part of it to me and i think
what you're saying about the monday
night football
makes that even more true you want that
on one of these three-letter networks
you want that thing simulcast on abc
and hey you're gonna get more viewers on
it just because it's broadcast
television as opposed to cable
television
but it also means i think that monday
night football can get these more
premium match ups that you would
sometimes see on thursday night because
it's going to be a marquee game more of
a marquee game again than i think it's
kind of been
over the course of the last few years
and mike the other interesting thing
that's been reported about that
was the fact that they could get some
flex games in the late
season from monday night football i
think that would kind of be a game
changer
and and i think that better than flexing
sunday to monday and monday to sunday
which creates logistical problems for
everyone involved
fans media teams everyone the idea
of a certain number of double headers
six o'clock nine o'clock right where
you you pick the two games for that
night
and you decide a week beforehand which
is the
prime matchup on abc and which is the
secondary match up on espn and
the the notion of expanding the windows
i think that's something to keep an eye
on as we go forward
as gambling develops as more states
come online with it as we get to the
point where real time betting
throughout the course of a game is is
easier to accomplish technologically
where
what you watch on tv is instantaneously
arriving in your house on your phone on
your tablet
from the game site the latency gets
ironed out of the process that's when
people can make bets
play after play drive after drive and
the more you
put games in one one game per window
the more people congregate the more
opportunities there are because
otherwise you got nine games going on at
one o'clock eastern on a sunday
those are wasted opportunities because
somebody yeah
it's not like people are gonna be making
bets on multiple games this play that
play this play that play there's not
enough time to do it
so i think a move toward more windows
two on monday night maybe one on tuesday
night
maybe squeeze another window into sunday
those are all things that i think we
need to keep an eye on and the
possibility of
of a double header element on monday
night we saw it this year
it was a pandemic reality and i think it
worked
and and i won't be surprised if that's
how they deal with the effort to pump up
the monday schedule
a couple of games late in the year and
then we'll decide
which one is worthy of the bigger
platform
yeah i think the monday night double
header idea is great because i think
look it i think it was pretty successful
just from even my standpoint
i'm sitting here and i'm watching
multiple games on monday night and it's
like wow you get to the end of the first
one it's like man there's another one
that's about to kick off this is awesome
so look you already have these windows
that are built in on sunday i think
fewer games
on sunday whether then you say all right
you have a few games on the one clock
window
you're more in the four o'clock you have
one at night i think that that is worked
pretty well but
when you have these international games
sometimes and if you know
we can have international games again in
2021 who knows what that's going to be
once we get to september but you can
have that early early window where
again the jaguars seem to always be
playing in that and then you could have
two double two games on monday where
then you're saying all right look it's a
double header and you can then figure
out
which which matchup is going to be the
prime match up and which one is going to
be the b
team match up i think the the schedule
flexibility that would give
and the more opportunities like you said
for sports betting that that would
present me something that's really
really beneficial to the league as a
whole mike
legalized gambling is going to lead to a
push for more things on which to bet
more windows more games and eventually
mark it down more teams
there's enough quarterbacks now to have
more
teams i feel like that's just a matter
of time
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports